j'ai envie de voir si vous saviez danse
et surtout on va vous mettre plusieurs
musiques à la suite et voudrait danser
sur chacune d'entre elles d'accord vous
avez été champion du monde de quoi les
lilas été champion du monde les deux
champions de france c'est bien
800 yamaha coupe du monde sera champion
du monde champion du monde de cours est
de 7 ça ouais ouais ouais elle est
championne du monde de slam danse latine
et 8e dans la coupe du monde de salsa
matière à ce mouvement de salsa
il a dit qu'ils ont c'est comme une mise
bottes et qu'ils aient des fringues et
comme de la merde nous faire une petite
danse latine déjà tu sais que tu es
libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette famille un la famille
market on danse 2 secondes et on s'en va
on en demande trop avait ses qualités
c'est un package envie de jouer et déjà
rendez vous on ne peut pas travailler
comme ça donc on va faire mon jeu plus
attention je vous met des musiques à
chaque fois voudrait danser sur
n'importe quelle musique pour savoir si
vous êtes bon si vous êtes sexy sur
n'importe quelle musique j'adore parce
que ça va ils ont désormais il parle
avec lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
légales sont en quête d'un cinquième les
frères barclay s ils sont ok c'est toute
la maison partout ils sont quand même
son frère kent contre enquête
alors les gars je vous mets des musiques
va vous mettre des musiques origines ça
partira ça partira pas celles à risque
d'accord vous dansez sur ce que vous
pouvez et vous danser la danse que vous
pouvez sur ses patins génériques télé ça
peut être ça peut être n'importe quoi
mais ça peut être une musique d'attenté
ça peut être tout ce que vous évoquez
attention c'est parti on y va ouais
boyard tu vas regard allez-y
[Musique]
obama
[Applaudissements]
ça
jingles et couscous et barda
[Applaudissements]
m
je vais danser maintenant sur la
sonnerie d'un téléphone
[Musique]
c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous les voulez vous dire
vous le savez le port dit qu'elle fait
chaud le visage doux d'un autre mec qui
vient de mettre l'album moment j'avais
compris ou pas sait on si je fais on
fait ce qu'on peut me voir s'il vous
plaît sarcelles où vient le voir alors
leader dans la danse qui se referme sur
facebook est une autre chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après ces annonces à s'adjuger téléphone